let's go next to our caller from the 845
area code caller from 8:45 say hello
tell us your name tell us where you're
calling from hey this is Mark Benjamin
from congers New York all right what's
going on mark as of late I've been
reading the dictators handbook through
audiobooks and I was one and they tend
to bring up keys to power like how
you're regardless of the type of
politician you are you need certain
people to keep you afloat to kind of
keep your power in check and if you
don't do well you'll just get screwed
over by that so what are Trump's keys to
power and like in a non moralistic terms
how do they um in a non moralistic way
but rather practical way how do we focus
on having them turn on him or having
them push in towards a pod net positive
action well there's two different things
there one is how do we turn Trump to
being a positive force the other is how
do we get rid of him I think that the
more important conversation is how do we
get rid of him and that's going to
happen I want to give me more as a side
note I'm sorry I was a gehrig me more
and scared me more as a side note that's
what and and scares you more yeah he
seems like a flat-out racist and just
more tears I gotcha
listen here's the thing okay so for
other Republican Party officials Trump
maintains control over other Republican
elected officials by their fear that if
they turn against Trump if they are the
only ones to act or part of a small
group that they will end up losing they
will either lose re-election or they'll
become the targets of Trump's ire and
we've seen that happen to Senate
Republicans so for Trump to turn a trump
to lose control over Republican elected
officials there needs to be either
number one group action so that they all
say listen he can't turn against all of
us he'll be by himself
that's sort of tough or you need to take
away Trump's popularity to such a degree
that Trump turning against them doesn't
matter okay so that's as far as the
elected officials go as far as the
electorate turning against Trump at this
point they have been so successfully
primed to see any critical reporting of
Trump as fake and to disbelieve anything
that seems to contradict what Donald
Trump says that I actually am
increasingly thinking they're a lost
cause and what we need to focus on is
just getting more people to vote him out
in 2020 than to try then trying to
change the minds of individual voters
because it's an exercise in futility and
it's very difficult you can get ten
people to vote that might not have voted
more easily than you can change the mind
of one committed trumpet that's very
optimistic of you
all right great to hear from you I
appreciate it thank you one of today's
sponsors is privacy comm slash Pakman
this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it you just take a few
seconds to link your debit card or bank
account to privacy coms mobile app or
browser extension for Firefox and Chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there
are a ton of different advantages to
shopping and paying bills with a system
like this everything is totally secure
and encrypted and in some situations you
can earn 5% cash back on your purchases
it's all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets 5 dollars towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link below